what's going on guys this is rob and
with loki exploring the multiverse and
all that kind of stuff here on geek
culture explain i'm going to give you
guys a rundown on how the multiverse
works in marvel comics now if you guys
want a more in-depth explanation here i
will link you guys to jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers at comics
explained which will give you an
explanation in a far more
in-depth way over the course of i don't
know something like nine hours so the
basic premise of a universe you guys
don't need explained
to you right you guys understand that
galaxy solar system stars planets life
but beyond that what you have are a
couple different things you've got
cosmic entities you've got pocket
dimensions and you've got a place called
the dimension of manifestations which is
incredibly important so universes in
marvel comics are
infinite insofar as they can stretch
into infinity so the way these things
work is of course you have a big bang
and that's what creates a universe if a
big bang
expands the universe outward the big
crunch starts pulling it inward and then
once it reaches that final point it'll
just condense down into an infinitely
small space and explode outward in a big
bang
giving birth to a new universe but the
reason why marvel says universes are
infinite is because until it reaches
that point where it starts to contract
the universe can just keep going and
going and going there's no limit to how
big
a universe can get and that's why you
have some universes that are actually
bigger than
others in marvel comics now within
universes you have a
litany of pocket dimensions some of
which are easily accessible and some of
which can only be accessible through
special circumstances something like
asgard requires a wormhole the bifrost
bridge for example to access that so you
can't get in a ship and just start
flying in a forward direction across the
universe and eventually reach asgard you
have to actually pass through a
dimensional barrier
to enter into that pocket dimension the
dark dimension this is an interesting
case the dark dimension was originally
just a large singular place somewhere
along the line it was never really
explained to us why all we know is that
there was just some kind of a conflict
that basically shattered the dark
dimension into a series of other pocket
dimensions and so these pocket
dimensions gave us beings like mephisto
and nightmare and so on and so forth
they're called the splinter realms
sometimes they're called the nightmare
realms or the dream dimensions or the
hell realms or whatever the cases
regardless of how you slice it that's
where those little individual places
come from now beyond these small little
pocket dimensions you have cosmic
entities and cosmic entities are
basically ideas given form so you know
when you get hungry you have like a kind
of pain
in your stomach imagine you didn't get
that and imagine a being just
appeared to you and said you're hungry
it's time for you to eat and that's when
you knew you were hungry that's how
cosmic entities work now cosmic entities
as they appear in marvel comics
they can just appear in a physical form
if they want to but most times
they don't instead what they do is they
travel to a realm called the dimension
of manifestations which is ran by
being named anthropomorpho and
anthropomorpho creates what are called
m bodies which are basically physical
forms that the essence or the idea of
the cosmic entity
basically fills and then they appear in
the marvel universe now there's
all kinds of cosmic entities so we're
not going to run over all of them here
but the more significant
ones are like eternity and infinity
eternity represents
time and infinity represents space
eternity being how long
a universe could potentially go on for
and infinity representing how much space
the universe could actually occupy
beyond that you have guys like the
stranger you've got eon galactus is
considered a cosmic entity even though
he originated from a mortal being that
basically died with his previous
universe and then merged with that
universe's version of eternity but at
the end of the day
it all still counts now something to
know is that by and large
every universe has this form and
function every universe has its own
version of asgard every universe has its
own version of dormammu its own eternity
its own infinity it has its own
individual variations of cosmic entities
like galactus its own pocket dimensions
all that kind of stuff and then you move
into a much larger scope the multiverse
as you guys guess
is a combination of different universes
but there are beings out there that are
unique to the multiverse itself so with
this multiverse you have the living
tribunal now the rule of the living
tribunal has shifted a lot over the
years in normal comics originally it was
just maintaining magical balance in any
one particular universe
over the years the tribunal's role has
shifted a lot worse basically just kind
of become a plot device right where the
living tribunal just shows up if the
story calls for him and that's basically
it and so from there you go into
cosmic entities in relation to the
multiverse that if somebody like
eternity is basically the answer to the
question what if the universe could get
up and walk around
that the multiversal eternity is
basically the same way that the
multiversal eternity represents the
infinite expanse of the multiverse
itself if the multiverse could get up
and walk around it would be the
multiversal eternity
you've also got a few other beings out
there like oblivion oblivion's a really
interesting case because marvel's never
really given us a definitive example of
how powerful
oblivion is it's usually just fans
referencing the role oblivion plays
within marvel comics as an indication of
how powerful it is and rightfully so
oblivion basically represents the
nothingness between the death and
rebirth of
everything and so the idea is that
oblivion is incapable of dying depending
on what fan you talk to
some people will say oblivion is second
to the one above all the one above all
of course being the being that created
everything in existence now this begs
the question
if something like the bifrost allows a
person in a universe to travel to a
pocket dimension within that universe
is there something that allows a person
to leave their universe and travel to
another universe and the answer is
yes now there's actually quite a few of
these so you do have things like the
florida everglades
i know it's weird and then you have
things like the crossroads you have
stuff like the imcron crystal and even
the negative zone to a degree when it
comes to these various things they're
depicted in different ways the
crossroads for example is depicted as a
whole host of winding paths that the
florida everglades when you pass into
that nexus of reality you basically get
the same thing the florida everglades
are kind of interesting because they're
guarded by the man thing and so when you
approach the man thing swamp he'll touch
you and if you feel fear
it'll incinerate you if you feel no fear
you'll be allowed to pass when it comes
to something like the emcron crystal
this is quite literally a crystal that
exists
out there in the universe and that every
universe has its own version of the
emcron crystal think of it as something
akin to a hallway of doors now if you
actually enter the imron crystal you'll
actually encounter what's called the
white hot room which is where
only individuals who are perfect hosts
for the phoenix force can actually
reside jean grey was a really good
example of that but these individual
places can be accessed through magical
means
a person who can alter reality can do it
these individuals are basically able to
kind of pass through these different
barriers with the exception of the nexus
of realities and the man thing swamp
anybody can go through there but once
you
access these different places you can go
to different universes now the biggest
issue that you have here is unless
you're somebody who's experienced in
doing it like the fantastic four doctor
strange or something like that you can
get lost
because it's not as though you go into
this hallway of doors within the imran
crystal basically and there's like
numbers that label every single universe
you could literally spend just
infinite amounts of time passing from
one universe to the next and never get
to where you need to be
and if you're not keeping track of where
you've been you'll never get back to
your home universe and so from there you
go into the various multiversal
organizations themselves and again we're
not going to cover all of them here the
video on comics explained we'll run
through a lot of that stuff but to
highlight some of the finer points as
most of you guys know the time keepers
and the time variance authority exist
on a multiversal level the roles that
the timekeepers in the tva play in
mobile comics are basically identical to
the roles of the marvel cinematic
universe
a big difference is that the timekeepers
exist to ensure they actually come into
existence so they're kind of dicks and
they're usually pretty selfish then
you've got things like the starlight
citadel in
other world which is basically kind of a
gateway to other realities and it's
essentially the home to the captain
britain court the captain britain core
is basically a multiversal team so
there's one captain britain in every
single universe that's designed to
protect that universe which is really
kind of a crappy role because the
captain britain core
those guys aren't very powerful but then
you've got organizations like the exiles
which are designed to travel around the
multiverse facing off against various
threats and is actually a team
consisting of various individuals
from different universes you've got the
temporal empire of king the conqueror so
basically whenever king goes back in
time
in marvel comics traveling into the past
is not enough to create an alternate
reality you have to actually do
something and so there are stories where
kane the conqueror has fought against
the avengers what this does
is it splits off a litany of alternate
realities where he defeated all of the
avengers he defeated only half the
avengers he defeated one avenger and
then was defeated by the rest now
there's all kinds of different universes
based on that and so the temporal
empire of kang is not really a temporal
empire ruled by one particular person
it's a giant multiversal empire ruled by
virtually every version of kang that's
out there and they're largely referred
to as the council of kings and then
you've got places like
limbo which is where a mortise resides
and so on and so forth but the
multiverse is a pretty complex place and
there's a lot that goes on there in the
realm of marvel comics so again
if you guys want to learn more about
this stuff with regards to the
multiverse and marvel comics
make sure you check out the video in the
description which will link you to
comments explained
which will run over all that stuff and
make it easier for you guys to grasp but
with that being said
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace